sly stallone is speaking out on what
went wrong after his ex jennifer filed
for divorce break up
i can't relate
we just went in different directions i
will always love her that's what the 76
year old told tmz just one day after
this seemingly telling post sly
displaying the sneakers he had altered
from his last rocky movie after breaking
two toes on set we kept
moving forward kept moving forward so i
keep this as a reminder that when it
hurts sometimes that's a good omen
because when it comes to easy it usually
is not very very good sly is said to be
blindsided by jennifer's filing but were
there clues here's a quick timeline of
recent trouble
august 8th that's the 54 year old model
leaving west hollywood hot spot craigs
without her wedding ring from the top
flies
[Music]
sly had been in oklahoma filming the
upcoming paramount plus series tulsa
king three days earlier he showed off
his newly acquired dog named after his
character dwight how do i wash it one
report claimed the couple ended things
because jennifer didn't want sly to have
the rottweiler he denied that but 11
days after announcing he got the pooch
stallone covered up that tattoo of his
wife's face with the dog from rocky his
rep told e.t it was to hide flaws made
while trying to refresh his jennifer tag
sly also has this ink of her as an angel
on his back welcome
we have been with the couple throughout
their 25-year marriage including at home
with their kids but this isn't their
first breakup i was with sylvester for a
little over a year
i got pregnant back in 1994 sly ended
things with jennifer after thinking he'd
fathered a child with model janice
dickinson when we both found out that
the child wasn't his
he went on his way sly and jennifer
would tie the knot three years later of
course
[Music]